environ 200 personnes s'entraînent ici
chaque jour la piscine de satory situé
dans le quartier militaire de versailles
vient d'être sauvée d'une fermeture
définitive le mystère l'intérêt nous
avait dit qu'il fermerait définitivement
la piscine pour des raisons d'économies
budgétaires à partir du 1er juillet et
donc pour nous c'était une vraie
préoccupation ce que ces piscines est
nécessaire non seulement pour le
quartier de satory mais aussi pour les
activités des clubs et notamment le
grand club de versailles de natation le
snd versailles a donc négocié cette
décision et a pu trouver une solution
la commune ne pouvant assumer
financièrement le rachat de la structure
le ministère de l'intérieur toujours
propriétaire lui a confié la gestion des
dieux et un transfert de gestion et donc
on cite la ville de versailles va lancer
une opération dite d'autorisation
d'occupation temporaire ce qu'on appelle
une aute des structures juridiques qui
permet de confier à un gestionnaire on
verra lequel le soin de faire marcher la
piscine un contrat pour cinq ans
renouvelables mais avec la possibilité
d'arrêter à tout moment des deux côtés
la ville investit c'est environ 120
milles euros par an pour la location de
lignes d'eau son budget restera le même
la piscine utilisé essentiellement par
les militaires associations et scolaire
ne sera pas ouverte au public